I'm gonna fight The Witch Hunt I'm gonna
take care of clearing my name and I look
forward to doing that Santos pleaded not
guilty to financial charges including
fraud money laundering and lying on his
disclosure forms during his 2022
campaign
do you have that they don't have because
it's extensive oh I I have plenty of
evidence that we will now be sharing
with the government in this case to make
sure that I can defend my interview
Federal prosecutors allege Santos
encouraged donors to make campaign
contributions through a company and use
the money to pay for personal expenses
including luxury designer clothing and
credit card payments Santos is also
accused of collecting thousands of
dollars in pandemic era unemployment
insurance while making six figures at a
florida-based investment firm